[Music]
thank you
as I braced myself for another episode
of succession planning incest flaunting
in while walking I find myself wondering
do they have these caskets ready to go
or is the funeral put on hold until one
is made if they're pre-built how early
is too early to have one ready without
being in bad taste also while we're
being disrespectful did they really need
the whole casket I mean she was just a
skeletal Ash pile at the end wouldn't
have been easier to make a bust and save
everyone The Crafty time none of the
people out here on the Rocks would hear
this whispered funeral speech for Layna
so why risk the rocks at all it's not
like anyone's trying to take a perfectly
cinematic picture show tries to coax
sadness from me but forgets that it's
conditioned me to feel nothing while
watching because everyone dies a
horrible death regardless of my
investment
Otto's back hip wait a minute he's the
hand again we didn't even see Lionel die
wait his name was Lionel right anyway
this badge is doing the narrative leg
work of confirming that Lionel strong is
dead in that viserys has decided he's
able to trust Otto again why does this
show persist in refusing to give me that
I actually want to see
me too aegon me too I mean Eamonn aegon
Eamonn wait aegon no no Eamonn
definitely aiming no it's aegon aegon
100 right it took so long for this
casket to drop into the sea and while I
know that we're meant to feel the
importance of the ritual we have other
things to be interested in here for
example renira isn't Queen yet let's get
to that because we want to see her rule
for a long long time okay crew we've got
five minutes of staring followed by 20
minutes to some it's so dark it's
essentially unwatchable but before that
let's release the dragons that'll buy
some Goodwill and maybe keep people uh
guys why did the dragons even look
miserable now the next eight minutes are
filled with post-decade skip characters
that we barely know anything about
exchanging uncomfortable glances pepper
into this sad soup the awkward bubbling
tension between children who are groomed
to despise each other the result is a
viewer like myself forced to fill in the
quiet spaces with my own version of what
the glances in anger mean it's
exhausting I hate it
nope but you know who should be this
[ __ ] smirky [ __ ] that everyone
should be suspicious of at this point
dragons
flesh weaving dragons of thread sharing
your poetry with arachnids of my seat
and high tide will be yours one day you
sir they will not I mean I have no idea
if that's true or not but I'm willing to
wager that all these people die horrible
deaths and none but the rats live
happily ever after retrieval subtlety
okay we've given the show a lot of stick
for putting us through conversations
that are boring and don't do anything to
progress the story but they've somehow
found something even more boring
watching those same conversations from
the perspective of someone who can't
even hear what's being said go to bed a
quarter an entire quarter of this
episode has been spent at the funeral of
a character we barely got to know it
certainly didn't know long enough to
truly care about and yes I know the
funeral is a thematic backdrop for the
actual Mead of the scene but when that
meat is a Patty of reminding us that the
newly appointed Lord strong is creepy no
one likes ranera aegon is a jerk and the
king is still decomposing then I'm gonna
want a refund for my meat because it
tastes like and disappointment so and
forgive me if I'm wrong here usually
usually you're able to see what's on
screen but because this show is stupid
it decided to spill dark ink into a
black void retrieve a sample with a
spoon made of stir and Satan's tears
smear the residue on a pane of glass and
used that as a filter over the cameras
for basically the remainder of this
episode in order to help everyone out
I'll be narrating what happens next to
speed us along he's drunk he's an ass
he's a thief he's drunk and he's
tolerated she's sad and he's ambitious
She's Horny he's bored oh there's an
ocean here and a beachy tent thing for
such an occasion as impromptu
fornicating a big dragon is sad and then
stolen the dragon flies around for
nearly five minutes kids talk to kids
about kid stuff the two people that
[ __ ] on a beach aren't picking sand
out of their cracks Kids Go full on Lord
of the Flies with the Torchlight finally
ending the complete darkness I gave up
the idea of wearing a crown a generation
the good as you Lord husband who refuses
to abandon this Pursuit rhemes would be
excellent in TV sins and please Corliss
give it up too we've had this rainy
should have been Queen debate over and
over and over and over and over and over
and we get it he thinks she should be
Queen she is not Queen he does not like
that she is not Queen she does not mind
that she is not queen stop it I know
better than anyone that our marriage is
a fact but I at least make the effort to
maintain appearances an effort wasted it
seems when others would send his lover
to fetch him out of the water and not
you I remember a child wasn't wasn't
there a scene where these two nearly
[ __ ] in a brothel think the innocence
of childhood wasn't really an issue at
any time so why is it coming up now also
they hook up in a brothel they almost
hook up at a wedding dinner they hook up
on the damn beach after his wife's
funeral I'm beginning to think that
they're basing this relationship on a
mutual love of exhibitionism and
strangely that didn't even rank in the
top 10 reasons you don't date your uncle
article I just finished are we finally
through the bar where we get to assume
Renae is now pregnant so we can finally
care about Danny and John's eventual
appearance in this world look I know
we're giving this episode a hard time
but it Bears repeating that I truly am
stunned to find ourselves once again
sitting that we can't see [ __ ] in a Game
of Thrones episode without jacking up
the contrast on my TV and undoing all
the effort that presumably went into
this day for night filming Choice also
for those who may not know day for night
is a filming technique used to simulate
night without having to actually film at
night saving a bunch of time and money
but at the expense of the end User it's
kind of like taking your kid to the
Disney Store because it's closer and
cheaper than Disneyland but somehow even
more disappointing just when I thought I
couldn't sit in more walking the show
dangles a beautiful new example of
wasted wandering in the form of a dragon
walking on air if Fabio can't make it
through a single roller coaster ride
without taking a goose to the face
there's no way Eamonn can make it
through the birds here question I asked
whenever I see one of viserys and
Allison's kids appear on screen somehow
makes its way into the episode question
I ask whenever one of renera's kids
appears on screen somehow makes its way
into the episode
question I've been asking for the last
15 day for nine minutes somehow makes
its way into the episode maybe your
cousins can find you a picture odd nude
suit here of course the easy sin here is
kids but I just don't feel as if that
covers my level of discomfort in being
made to watch half a dozen children
beating the Monday to Friday snot out of
each other and one of them losing an eye
so let's send the fact that somebody
thought of the scene wrote it got the
kids to act it out and then assumed
millions of people would enjoy it but
also kids how could you allow such a
thing to happen I really hope he's
asking this question into a mirror like
how are there no adults watching the
kids even though they all stand to
inherit massive responsibilities and
lands and crowns and how they all snuck
out to kill each other without one
person noticing prayer guard's so hard
to find during the stabbing parts of the
episodes over an insult
my son has lost an eye well you know the
old saying an eye for an eye I know who
your real daddy is where is Elena
entertaining is Young Squires Adventure
okay we're about to get into a big huhan
kerfuffle because accusing the princess
as kids of being bastards is a
treasonable offense but Alison can get
away with calling out princely nor
sexuality and Fidelity as if it's
nothing more than a heavy night at the
tavern that is insufficient my thoughts
about this entire [ __ ] Creek will
make it into I think you get the message
by now I am not having a good time
rather than disarm Allison everyone
stops to see if her slashing resulted in
a visible wound rather than stop the
bleeding everyone stops to look at
Allison to see if her slashing resulted
in remorse what that rogamund has done
in winning Vega to our side it's worth a
thousand times the price he paid a
thousand eyes I know he's being
hyperbolic but you try getting your eye
removed a thousand times before you go
throwing around false equivalencies like
that my goodness For the Love of All
That is Holy use a smaller needle also
actually here's an idea stop showing us
people getting stitches I have an
imagination and as I'm already using it
to think of all the things I'd rather be
watching right now I may as well use
some of that bandwidth to imagine the
stitches myself also also do you think
that the writers have a certain quota
for their series like we need to see the
body endure brutality at least 14 times
each episode or on average
1921 times each season bonus points for
needles and if they do why do they think
that keeps people interested also third
of his name someday I will remember to
not eat food while watching this show
yeah but I'm sure even in these
primitive times there's some ointments
that can oh she's being metaphorical
isn't she carry on these are dangerous
times yeah don't say must be a day that
ends and why God why isn't this episode
over yet we could not marry unless we're
dead I know let's talk about the
villain's plan and for Clarity on this
occasion the villains were talking about
are Damon and renera they're gonna trick
everyone into thinking that Lenor was
killed by his lover in a sword fight in
the heart of driftmark but actually send
him in said lover off to A Whole New
World so that renere is for you to
immediately marry Damon look even if
this plant goes off without a hitch
which of course it does because they
pull in Ocean's 11 and Montage it as
it's being described to us that still
leaves lanor out in the world capable of
exposing them the second he realizes
life is a commoner ain't all it's
cracked up to be also putting aside the
fact that the robbing cordless and
rhaenice of their last child Rainier and
Damon both acknowledged that remarrying
so quickly will immediately attract all
of the murdery suspicions to be cast on
renera well then I suppose they just
think hey [ __ ] it if we're lucky we're
about to hit another six year time Jump
so we won't have to deal with any of
these pesky immediate consequences
now showing favoritism introducing a
brand new character in the last 10
seconds of your episode
just an eye godself integrates me with
despair so what's your story sleds why
wait
foreign
well peeing in the ocean was my bucket
list item is this
or a mistake
let me see
yay and I password fix them up real nice
who spoke these lies to you
what where do you think you're going I'm
sorry
for you I'm the one who kills the queen